hey
can you make that straighter
that's what she said
did you plan that
no
can you make that straighter
that job looks hard
you should put your mouth on that
how can you even use that one naturally
blowing up balloons i thought he's
leaving our plan worked we saved our own
honeymoon and fun bonus we cheered up
holt yes okay it's time to celebrate you
know what that means this bee needs a c
in her a oh my god this babe needs a
coconut in her arms oh
i thought you were saying this music oh
my god yeah that was my reaction all
right i'll go get us a couple of
coconuts hey
connie cabbage what's good today green
cabbage is always a safe bet red cabbage
is good i mean you can't go wrong that's
the fun thing about cabbage one of the
fun things oh
[Music]
time to crack this margarita
bodies get a chart on that can't be
chowded in here
what the hell is going on oh yeah that's
the new charred stand i suppose that's
one way to sell vegetables we got swiss
chard we got white shard we got charred
poppers and for all you freaking vegans
out there we got shark shots yeah
um chart is so bitter hey did you get a
chance to sign off on that booklet i
gave you well i read it but it seems
like your farmer's market rules may be
specifically targeting charred bodies
what how
no visible cleavage no strobe lights no
charred related
innuendo attention everyone hello
uh yes i just want you to know that uh
this is not my decision but from here on
out we can no longer be friends
and when we talk about things here we
must only discuss uh work-associated
things
and uh you can consider this my
retirement from comedy
and in the future if i want to say
something funny or witty or do an
impression i will no longer
ever do any of those things
does that include that's what she said
mm-hmm yes
wow that is really hard
you really think you can go all day long
well
you always left me satisfied and smiling
so
that's what she said
for you
and you
and you what are these these
are stds
what are you talking about buddy stds
save the dates for vivian of my wedding
ah
yes hey just out of curiosity how many
people have you given stds to lots
like a hundred
what's going on
uh oh okay i get it std has another
meaning
you're gross no one else is gonna think
that everyone is going to think that but
it's sweet that your mind didn't go
there thank you it is kind of sweet will
your first dance be too you give me
fever will you be serving crabs at the
reception do you have herpes guys this
is my wedding this is important to me no
more jokes you're right and we're sorry
yes we love you buddy warts and all
sorry i made a rash decision i was
itching to say it okay i'm done
i have an std
so just rsvp or yeah the number's right
on there we can't wait to see what the
heck you're gonna do next
step one up here les
paul are you okay uh
oh
that was
the second most awkward way a man has
ever grabbed my breast
what if we're scaling cliff and i start
to fall can i grab onto your boob for
support no tom don't her boob kills my
boob does not kill paul did not die he
had a heart attack which required an
octuple bypass
besides the pawnee's son said that my
chest saved his life
jim big fire in your house your client
dunmore high school sent out their prom
invitations on this paper went home to
all the kids yeah i gotta call that one
no no no not good enough this is a
keystone account i want you in the
school in person i want you to bring a
partner i'll go no sweet cheeks we need
somebody who's actually made a sale andy
you go william do little at your service
aka will do
yeah i'm definitely gonna go along no no
i need two men on this that's what she
said no time but she did no time
santiago i've been your co for four
years by now you should be able to stand
up for yourself even if that means
telling me off you're right
just say the word and i will tell you
off okay tell me off about losing your
pen oh
right now
okay well makes me feel
pretty annoyed good
go on it grates my cheese i mean
it just really grates my cheese
gur
oh santiago you're faking faking what
did you hear that gur just admitted okay
fine i was faking the whole time but i
only did it because i wanted you to
enjoy it that ruins it i mean it's
supposed to be good for both of us it
was good just because i didn't get angry
doesn't mean i didn't get anything out
of it but the whole point is for you to
get angry
did you even get close
what about your last ceo could he make
you angry well you know what i don't
want to know don't tell me i don't want
to know
how was your meeting
it was fine pretty straightforward
short meeting you know he's a busy guy
yes very busy look at this article
no
the story of this story is that it won't
stop developing the mystery woman who
met with councilman dexhart last night
appears to be a government employee
named leslie north oh my god according
to unconfirmed reports in the pawnee sun
the two bent an elbow at this local
watering hole and although they left
separately no one knows where they woke
up together
heard hapley channel 4 news
okay
all right
there we go
oh
okay that's nice everybody enjoying
their meal
hey babe yeah how about we take the beer
sign down until our guests leave and
then we can discuss it no
no
i'm gonna leave it up i think it ties
the whole room together
okay
[Music]
jan thinks hunter is very talented
you know what
i don't think he's that good at least
he's an artist pfd i'm a screenwriter
and i'm a candle maker but you don't
hear me bragging about it no all you do
is you get me
to try to work on my rich friends for an
investment opportunity man i would love
to burn your candles you burn it you buy
it oh good i'll be your first customer
you're hardly my first
there's australia
so
how was your night of work i'm not
asking about your personal life i don't
care about you personally i mean i'm
neutral i mean who are you floundering
is worse than silence oh cool go go go
go go go go no doubt no doubt no doubt
yeah it's elevator's slow huh that's
because you haven't pressed the button
that's why you're the captain
so smart
i'm gonna just
zoop
a number
geek blast of cold air coming out of
that box name of amy's sex tape hey man
come on not cool i'm going through
something just let me have this one okay
everyone
great news lots of old people have
chlamydia
seniors in pawnee have a lot of time on
their hands and what they're doing with
that time is going at it hard old people
style a lot of them haven't had proper
sex education and as a result stds are
having a field day it's amazing what a
few old guys can do with a little bit of
charm and a lot of crabs okay sex
avengers these old fogies are very set
in their ways they're hopped up on e.d
medication and they got nothing to lose
because they're close to death also
seniors can be pretty ornery actually i
think it's pronounced horny la telefona
el telefono
michael's having a hard time with the
gender part of spanish
so i told him to mark everything with
the international symbol for gender
and um
i should have been more specific your
office is full of genitalia
uh-oh hey so is low-key djell
that's what he says
you